it is such an honor to have you
here oh my God I'm so stoked I was like
wait what who's coming like it's the
coolest thing ever to be a singer and
have this talk show you never thought
you'd have and then get to meet all
these Heroes that you know I've been
listening to still listen to oh my gosh
so I'm going to start with this DOA cat
who I love just sampled was it Walk On
By Walk On By yeah yeah yeah is that so
cool you're like listening to the songs
like come right back around you it was
amazing I didn't know that it had been
recorded by her
and uh my granddaughter called wait they
don't have to they have to ask
permission for that right no not
really that's a whole separate episode
okay they sample it and that it's it's
theirs oh my gosh but and and my
granddaughter called me yeah as Grammy
yeah do do you know you're on a record
with
doat I said doah
who she she's she's a rapper and she's a
and she was explaining all of this to me
and I said okay and what song are we
talking about she said Walk On By
complet through the entire
song okay well apparently it's a major
hit for it oh no no it's huge paint the
town ready
yeah and I'm thrilled you know like I
said when I heard it had been done I
hope Walk On By as as good for her as it
has been for me yeah wonderful I think
what's cool about it too is like keep
I'm sorry you can clap you
clapping
um I think what's interesting too is you
know I grew up on that song I love a lot
Albert backra obviously a partner of
yours that you worked with a lot but um
I just think it's cool because it
introduce people like a whole different
generation to songs that they might not
have known absolutely and they're great
songs and finally they're being exposed
to yeah good music yeah amen yes yes so
I have to ask I didn't know this but
you're kind of the breakout moment for
you in your career was it it was the
first night that you were at Apollo
right yeah we did I did the um it was a
gospel show and my group The gospelaires
appeared on the amateur
night and uh it was really weird because
we we decided to sing a song called the
those that wait it was recorded by a
group out of Philadelphia the Imperials
yeah who were appearing on the gospel
show and uh we had no idea that they
were standing in the wings while we sang
their song oh were you happy you didn't
know that made me nervous happy me but
they were so kind to us you did a
wonderful job we're thrilled about you
singing a song and as it turned out we
won oh my gosh well people knew then but
I think what's even cooler is I heard
afterwards you they they were like Hey
we're looking for some singers to be on
this record and then you ended up in the
studio right after that yep sure did our
group went to uh New York New Jersey
Y A Boy records and um we did our very
first background session yeah for Sam
The Man Taylor and Nappy Brown wow and
that was our introduction to some the oo
and O and yay y that you hear on
recordings yeah I just think it's a
lesson too to say yes because you were
like you didn't even y'all you I heard
that you didn't even know what y'all
were saying yes to really we didn't even
know what background was
you're just like we'll do it I love that
because you never know what experience
will come from that you also had to this
I find this incredible because it it
just seems so long ago but it's actually
not that long ago but you toured during
segregation like yeah how incredibly
difficult was that it was interesting to
put it mildly uh something I'd never
experienced before yeah but it was a
case of um it was it became an adventure
for me uh one of those real Rebels
real ones yeah as me and I never
experienced anything that said oh you
can't sit here or you can't go there or
you can't drink this or you can't can't
sing this song Excuse
me what do you mean I can't no of course
that doesn't exist in my vocabulary yeah
it's almost like when they tell you that
it's like well you've now made it a red
button that I will be pressing pressing
yeah several times yeah I heard that one
time that you um the the club or
somewhere where you're performing said
they didn't want you to perform a
certain song and you're were like that's
in my set I'm going to sing it and then
y'all had to get off the stage they
ended up yeah they closed the show down
it was um Rachel's what I say and
there's a a verse in there that I
changed a little of tell you Ma I'll
tell your p and I'm going the word is
I'm going to send you back to Arkansas
but I said I'm going to say I'm going to
integrate Arkansas and they said oh you
can't say that yes I can watch me yeah
again I love and I did and they show out
yeah but it's
important
so I found this information out and I
was certain in my soul that you had
already been honored at the K Center
Honor like in my mind when I heard that
oh my gosh you're going to be honored to
the Kennedy Center I was like that
hadn't already happened like for me in
my brain that had already existed you
and so many others they thought I had
already been on it as a matter of fact
even the Kennedy understood I have been
honored I know I whenever it happened I
was like this has not happened yet
what's wrong with us it's a race I don't
understand the human race right now but
I mean you've you've worked with first
of all congratulations on that that's
incredible I think it's overdue but I
think it's incredible yes it is yeah um
well you have worked with and influenced
so many artists um in your career so we
wanted to talk about a few because
there's so many amazing on so we're
going to start with Elvis which I just
find So Random and awesome I heard a
story that was really cool about this
man with you but I want to make sure
it's real and it involved him like
signing some stuff yeah that happened
it's real tell him okay I was opening at
the Sans hotel and he was opening at the
well at Continental at that time and I
went over to see my aunt who was a
part of the Sweet Inspirations who were
backing him up on the show yeah and uh
was introduced to him and he's such a
nice man oh he's so pretty oh my God
he really was well he was so kind and he
says oh you're opening that I said yeah
he says I am too I said I know he said
well when you go to your nearest record
store you're going to find a surprise
for me I'm going to give you a gift I
said okay and in every single one of my
albums he had signed an autograph
photograph and stuck it inside and he
made the announcement from the stage his
stage that if you buy Dion walwick CD or
what they call CD Now was an album an
album yeah uh if you buy one you'll find
a surprise inside of it and it was a
photograph of him and he that is so
cool I mean just that an artist goes out
of their way to support another artist
that's incredible there's so many cool
things about that I bet cells were
well tell me yeah I was like I bet they
ran they were like and
okay so I I heard this story too which I
just you are so gangster so I heard that
you you called is it Snoop Dogg and
shite to your house for a meeting MH
please tell everyone this
story cuz you were listening to and this
is probably the age they were so wait so
you you were listening to a song with
your son son okay yes uh as turns out of
Damon who meet um was in the car with me
and this brat thing came
on and he was saying every single word
of it I turned the radio off how do you
know every single word of the song Oh
that's rap I said yeah okay I said do
you know the Declaration of
Independence uh no
silent I said well I tell you what until
you learn everything every single word
of the Declaration of Independence and
you you say it to mege to yeah yeah you
will not listen to this kind of
music oh Mommy yeah oh mommy is right
but then you called them to your house
yeah I called them to the house based on
the fact that they were all
using kind of not such nice words yeah
especially towards women yeah yeah and
you know I kind of uh and I was was one
of the very first ones to combat them
with what they were saying misogynistic
words calling young ladies out of their
name you know how many young ladies do
you see walking around on four legs with
the tail you know and calling them out
their
names I love it so I I made it my
business to let them know that you made
me part of the problem now I want you to
make me part of the solution
yeah I'll tell you what I I actually had
the opportunity to work with Snoop as
well and you must have made an impact
cuz he's so respectful he's like so
great to work with like wonderful now
like I told him that you're all going to
grow up you're G to meet somebody that
you're GNA fall in love with and of
course no no no you know yeah yeah yeah
and you're going to get married you're
going to have children and one of those
children is going to be the young lady a
little girl and eventually that little
girl is going to hear you recorded and
she's going to look at you and she's
going to ask you Daddy did you really
say that yeah I get in trouble for
saying damn my kids will call me out for
saying damn that's right yeah yeah can
you imagine the hell they're going to
get yeah yeah exactly but it happened
yeah you know and he he still to the day
thanks me yeah he's so cool I love him
yeah he's fun to work with you never
know what's going to happen
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home